>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Kate Zwaard: This next session
is a bit of a treat for me.
It gives me a chance to highlight
some Library of Congress staff
and partners, whose work I
think you'll find interesting
and relevant.
I'll start us off, and
then we'll have Matt Weber,
an assistant professor in the school
of communication and information
and co-director of Rutgers NetSci,
Network Science Research Lab.
Matt and his colleagues
Ian Milligan and Jimmy Lin
of Archives Unleashed
Incorporated led a datathon here
at the Library quite recently.
Matt is going to talk about
Archives Unleashed and its impact
on the web archiving community.
And last up we'll have
Deborah Thomas,
the library's program manager
for the National Digital
Newspaper program.
And Leah Weinryb Grohsgal,
a senior program officer
at the National Endowments of
Humanities, and coordinator
of the National Digital
Newspaper program.
Deb and Leah will talk about NEH's
recent chronicling America data
challenge, in which members
of the public submitted projects
using historic newspaper data
in a national competition.
But first, I'll start us off
by talking a bit about my team,
National Digital Initiatives,
who put this on today.
Who we are, what we've done and what
we're going to do in the future.
[ Background Noise ]
That's us, National
Digital Initiatives.
I'm going to wander
around, is [inaudible].
Great. So hello.
Hello? Great.
Hello, and welcome from
National Digital Initiatives.
Let me introduce you to my team.
There's me, I'm Kate, you know,
that's my picture and me, my face.
And Jamie Mirrors,
Jamie are you nearby?
There's Jamie.
Everybody, say hi to Jamie.
And Mike Ashenfelder.
Mike, do you mind standing
up and waving?
And Avy Potter.
Also, I think, you guys met Jane a
little bit earlier and also I think
in the crowd are Eugene
Flanagan and Colleen Showgun
from our executive management team.
They provide the support and
structure to make all this possible,
so if you like what we're doing,
please see them and thank them.
So as I mentioned,
and I'll talk a little
about National Digital Initiatives,
our team here, but first I want
to tell a quick story, that I
think illustrates what the Library
of Congress's long and exciting
history of technological innovation,
and that's the story of
Henriette Avram, whose work here
at LC replaced ink
on paper cataloging
with distributed electronic
cataloging records.
Henriette Avram was born in New
York in 1919, she did two years
of pre-med at Hunter College
and then left to start a family.
She was in her 30s when she
started learning how to program.
And I really like this story
because there are people
who will still tell you that if you
haven't been coding since you were
in diapers, you'll
never be able to do it.
And I'm here to tell
you that they're wrong.
She did it and she
changed the world.
Henriette and her team here
at the library created MARC,
which is a structure to hold
bibliographic information
for materials of all formats.
Does anybody in the room
remember card catalogs?
There are people like
that Colleen's age
that do not remember it
so don't laugh at me.
I really do miss the beauty
of them and the smell.
Like do you remember
how they used to smell?
But that's about all I miss.
They were kind of hard
to use, right?
And what Henriette and her team
gave us is the power to share
that information across oceans
and search it at a keystroke.
So right now I can sit at my
desk and search the holdings
of the British Library
to decide whether I want
to take a plane flight over there.
In the past, that would
have been impossible.
It also gave us the ability to
do really good precision recall,
you know, like searching with
a search string is much easier
than looking up beagle
and then realizing,
well that's not how someone
intended to catalog it,
you have to look up
a different name.
It, it also gave us shareability.
So it's the kind of work that
I find really interesting.
An application of effort here
made everybody's life a little
bit better.
So we could swap cataloging
records, we could have joint teams
where we could do the
copy cataloging.
You know, it really
improved all of our lives.
I think of Henriette Avram as sort
of a hidden hero of
computer science.
She's a personal hero of mine.
She came to libraries
from software like I did,
and really took her adopted home
as a place of her heart like I do.
But she did all of this before
computers were networked,
before relational databases
were a thing,
before character encoding
was really mature.
And I really like to just take
a moment and reflect on like,
what she was able to give
us at a time that you know,
this kind of sharing of information
was really, very limited.
And I think also when I think about
her story, it shows me the power
of combining disciplines,
which she did in her own self,
and I think that, knowing
many of you, that you do, too.
Right? You know, you have a data
science background and you work
in libraries, or you're a software
developer who's also a journalist.
And she did that herself.
But also we do that by
having rooms like this
where we share our knowledge
and get to know each other.
And I think that that's where
we see really cool seat changes,
where we can provide,
like cross disciplines.
Her work really started the digital
revolution in information science
and it's something we
carry forward today.
Here at the Library of Congress
but also broadly in the field.
I think about her as the person
who really started libraries'
commitment to open source.
So for those of you who work
in software in the libraries,
we're avid users and contributors to
open source but also standards work.
You know, we're famous for
getting committees together
and all working together, right?
And I think it really does lift the
tide, and that's the kind of work
that I'm really excited about.
It also shows, to me, how
innovation can look like a dot
in the timeline, but
it's really not.
So people say things like MARC was
released to the public in 1968.
But really it was ten years
of iterative releases,
and it only looks like a dot
in a timeline in hindsight.
And you can, and it still
continues to improve today.
You know, we have teams
of people working
on the standard here
and internationally.
It's an international standard
that now contains character support
for all current used languages.
You know? So it's this thing
that continues to blossom.
And I think about that in
relation to other work here
at the library, like LOC.gov.
It's also another dot
in the timeline
but is also a continuous improvement
and we add new collections
all the time.
My colleagues and OCIO
and library services,
put forward an enormous
amount of work
to release these new
treasures to the public.
Just this year we released a lot
of new collections including
George Patton's diaries,
the Chicago Ethnic Arts Projects,
and Walt Whitman's papers.
And I want to zoom down one more
level and just take a close look
at one collection that
we've released.
And we could just as easily
be looking at another,
at any of the other collections
like the ballroom dancing
instruction manuals
which are a hoot, you should
really check them out.
Or the 2014 election web archives.
But I picked this one because it's
really special to me and I find it,
I think it's really exciting.
Rosa Parks' personal papers and on
loan to the library for ten years
from the Howard G Buffet foundation.
They contain 7,500 pieces of
personal correspondence and papers
and 2,500 Princeton photographs
documenting her private life
and public activism on behalf of
civil rights for African Americans.
The materials came here, they
were assessed and stabilized
by the LC conservation division.
They were cataloged and described
by librarians and archivists.
Files were moved by
people and software.
They were assessed,
validated, prepared for access.
Meta-data was transformed.
Websites were created.
Search index were populated
and rights were assessed.
That's a few years worth of work
in less than 140 characters.
And those of you that are
librarians in the room,
you know that this is
just the job, right?
A bunch of invisible work to make
information find-able and usable.
But I kind of want to
make a big deal out of it
because we make a big
splash for cool new websites
and exciting new visualizations
but the sustained and careful
that it takes to get new information
out is something I think
we should really celebrate.
And I think it also
speaks to something
that I've been thinking a lot
about, which is this tension
between innovation
and sustainability.
And I think about this
in terms of LOC.gov
and the sustained effort takes
in getting new collections ready,
and the enduring power of MARC
and other bibliographic standards
like big frame, and I think of
Henriette Avram as my shiny beacon.
Because her, you know, level
of software in libraries,
but also because she really believed
in the power of infrastructure.
Which is something that I
can get really excited about,
like I think infrastructure's
really cool.
You know? It's the roads that we
all drive to get cool places, right?
And I think that groups like ours,
like National Digital Initiatives,
can either become or be perceived
as like, the cool new things group.
And I really don't want to do that.
I want to do things that lift the
tide and have a view to the future.
So with that all in mind as
we were doing our planning
for National Digital Initiatives,
we came up with a couple of goals
that I'd like to share
with you today.
The first one is to maximize
the digital collection,
the benefit of the
digital collection
to the American public
and to the world.
We have a lot of stuff here
at LC, we have a lot of it,
and a lot of it's publicly
available in digital.
We have 10 million historic
digital newspaper pages,
we have 1.2 million
prints and photographs,
we have the personal papers of
George Washington, Lincoln, Carlsig
and Jackie Robinson
and many other maps,
books and archived websites
and other treasures.
We have this really awesome team
here called educational outreach,
I don't know how many of you have
heard of it, but they focus on K
through 12 educators and students
and they prepare resources
and programs that help teachers
get material out to their students
from the library, teaching
with primary sources.
And I'd like to think about
how we can extend the benefit
that they give to advanced
scholars and to the public
and to the curious, and how
do we teach a new generation
of journalists to come to
the Library of Congress
for reference help
and for resources?
I think that's the kind of thing
that would be really
exciting to work on.
We'd also like to enable more
creative reuse of the collection.
The great mustaches of LOC, I tried
to grow one today for an example,
but it didn't really work out.
And people use these like for mugs
and t-shirts, and it's really neat
to see that kind of economic
benefit from things that are
in the public collective, but it
also, in its fun and exciting,
and it brings people to the
collection, too, which is great,
but it also services a more
important scholarly purpose, too.
Back to the Rosa Parks
collection for a second,
which contains this amazing
and powerful handwritten note
in which she says I have been
pushed around all my life and felt
at that moment that I
couldn't take it anymore.
This note gives us
insight into Parks
as an American hero in that moment.
But other pieces give us a more
fuller picture of her as a human.
And that's why I love her
pancake recipe, which was picked
up by the popular press
and food bloggers.
From what I hear, it
makes great pancakes.
Has anybody tried it?
>> Yes.
>> Kate Zwaard: Yeah?
How is it?
>> It's very good.
>> Kate Zwaard: Oh yeah?
Okay. Peanut butter is her
secret ingredient apparently.
But it really, the
pancake recipe I think,
helps us paint a fuller picture of
her as a person who had a family,
who had friends, you know,
who wasn't an icon frozen
in time, was a real person.
And really inspires us to think
about the power we could have
just being ourselves and thinking
about you know, what we could do.
And I think also it brings
people into the collection.
So people read on their
favorite food blog, this thing,
and I hope that inspires them to
think about what they could learn
about Rosa Parks from Rosa Parks
and brings them into the collection.
The second goal we have at
NDI is to incubate, encourage
and promote digital innovation.
We have a really small staff as
you just, as I just demonstrated.
Which I like actually, it helps us
keep focused, it makes us agile,
and it lets us try new things
without there being an impact
on the critical production
work of the library.
I think of us as sort of an
interface to the outside world.
I used to say a semipermeable
membrane, but I got a lot
of weird looks on that one,
so people told me to stop.
And in terms of an interface,
I think of us as being
out in the community, thinking about
standards, thinking about projects,
that would be really
interesting and relevant
to people inside the library, but
also being involved very closely
with our library colleagues
and what they're working on,
what they're interested in,
and helping the communication
path between those two.
How many of you remember
chemistry class?
So this is one of my favorite energy
diagrams, exothermic reactions
as you know from chemistry an
exothermic reaction happens
spontaneously, but sometimes
they need activation energy.
And I think that's true of many
of our projects here, right?
Like, we've got great ideas, we've
got tools, but we need a little bit
of help getting over the hurdle.
And I think in that case NDI
can provide a catalytic affect.
Right? We can be the catalyst
and we're not enzymes, right?
We don't have the power
of an enzyme.
But what we do have the power
of is we do have the power
of is knowing people,
knowing technology,
being able to connect folks.
So sometimes a little bit
of application of effort
from an outside team at just the
right time can get the ball rolling,
and I think that we
can help provide that.
I like to say that
libraries are poor, right?
We're not Silicon Valley.
But we're scrappy and
we like each other.
And that's our power, right?
We're like a stream over a boulder.
Our problems may be immovable,
but we are many, we are focused,
and we have a very long memory.
One of our focuses will be
building on relationships,
will be building relationships that
can lead to successful partnerships.
So we co-hosted DIPLA
fest a little while ago,
which was an exciting event
that brought many librarians
from across different libraries to
here into the national archives,
and we also co-hosted Archives
Unleashed a few months ago.
In the interest of no
spoilers, I won't talk much
about that because Matt's up next.
But I do wonder if I could tell
you just a quick story about that?
So we had, the teams were made
up of scholars, programmers
and librarians, which
is kind of unusual,
it differs from a classic hackathon
which is mostly programmers,
and that collaboration ended
up being really exciting
and awesome to watch.
And we had one team
that was looking at some
of the Supreme Court
web archive data,
and they were getting some
results, that, from a text analysis,
that they weren't expecting.
They looked a little wacky.
And, but luckily there as a
law librarian on the team,
and he said okay, well I know
a little bit about the contours
of the data, and the reason
you're getting this is
because blah, blah, blah.
Like he explained that like,
there's some weird artifacts
that you might expect.
So he helped them construct a query
that, that made the results work
out the way that they
could have expected.
And I think that really
illustrates the power
that libraries have in data science.
Right? Where else can you get, where
else can you go to get the data?
But also to talk with somebody who
really understands it intimately
and can help you with your research.
We're also working
on a proof of concept
for our digital scholars lab.
At the Library of Congress we
have the John W. Kluge Center,
which hosts scholars from all around
the world to be in residence here
at the library, to work
with our collections,
and also to create a community
together, and then share the results
of their work with policy
makers and the public.
And we're thinking about
how we can help support them
with advanced digital
scholarship research in partnership
with the Kluge Center staff.
To that end, we've engaged with
two outside experts, Dan Chudnov
and Michelle Gallinger, to do a
proof of concept implementation.
We're thinking about something very
lightweight that we can iterate
over time, and we will have a
report out after that's completed
and we hope that we'll have
something to share with you soon.
I'd like to introduce you
Ton Wong and Chris Adams,
our inaugural digital
innovation fellows at NDI.
They're doing a fellowship
that's focused
on demonstrating an innovative
use of the digital collections,
and we hope to broaden the
applicant pool for in future years,
so keep a look out for it.
Biking will not be a requirement,
that's just a coincidence.
So if you don't like
biking, don't worry.
And lastly, this meeting today, as
you could probably tell our theme
for this year was collections
as data.
And this is the capstone of
this event where we invite all
of you fine folks here
to chat together.
This is a particular love of mine
so I'm really excited about it.
But we're also exploring
other avenues,
like how can we encourage
more contributions
to open source and shared tooling?
How do we evaluate and
help with skill building,
technical skill building
in libraries?
And how do we improve on
shared infrastructure?
Things like that, where
we can apply a little bit
of effort to get a large result.
So contact us, we're
small, we're new,
but I'm proud of what we've
been able to accomplish already.
I hope today that you'll
enjoy our, this selection
of speakers that we've put together.
I'm really excited
to hear from them.
But I hope you'll also take
the opportunity to make friends
with each other, get
to know each other,
and think about Henriette
Avram and the power
that a determined individual
can have
over the course of human events.
Because I look around the room
and I see hundreds of you,
and more importantly I see
a network of professionals
that can really help
actualize those ideas.
So think big in a sense.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> Matthew Weber: Good morning.
I'm Matt Weber, I'm an assistant
professor at Rutger's University.
I'm in the department of
communication in the school
of communication and information,
and it's really an
honor to be here today.
Thank you to Kate and to her
team for organizing this.
Thank you for inviting me back
after that chaos that we created
when we were here in June.
I had the privelege of being here in
June with my colleagues Ian Milligan
and Jimmy Lin, both of whom are
faculty at University of Waterloo,
outside of Toronto up in Canada, to
host the Archives Unleashed event.
It was the second iteration of
Archives Unleashed and I want
to tell you a little bit about
the Archives Unleashed journey,
what we aim to accomplish,
and why I see this as being
such an important movement and
important initiative for engaging
with collections as data.
So Archives Unleashed is an agenda
that Ian, Jimmy and I put together
to address what we see
as a central problem
of web archives being a tremendous
untapped resource for scholars,
something that has incredible
potential for research and yet,
scholars are relatively unaware
of how archives can be utilized,
what we can do with them.
We came up with this idea, a little
more than a year ago, when Jimmy,
Ian and I were at a
conference together.
We were at a reception
afterwards and as we do
at these receptions we were standing
around a bar table drinking a
few beers, and we were talking
about the different data sets
that we had, and we were talking
about under-utilized
these data sets are.
And we jokingly said, we've
got to do something about this,
we have to figure out how
we can better educate people
and how we can unleash the power
of the archives that we have,
and Jimmy jokingly said, we
have to unleash the archives,
come on guys, we've got to do this.
And I should have run away
screaming at that point, because low
and behold we actually came up with
a way to start educating people
about how to utilize
archives as a research tool.
And so we saw this opportunity to
develop a forum for researchers
to engage with archives
and to learn about the ways
in which these can be utilized
in their research agendas.
Web archives are an amazing
resource, but access and tools
for utilization are often a problem.
We're seeking to address that.
We're seeking to keep calm and
hacked and to engage with the data.
Our vision behind this
is interdisciplinary,
and our goal in this
as Kate highlighted,
is to bring together researchers
from different backgrounds
because in part, we've
realized that in order
to create an active research agenda,
to bring researchers in to the fold
to work with web archive data,
we need to bring together
different disciplines.
Point in case, I'm a communications
scholar, Ian's a historian,
and Jimmy's a computer scientist.
We come from entirely different
disciplinary backgrounds,
we speak entirely different
languages as academics, and yet,
together in the same room,
we're able to work with data,
and create meaning out of
that data as we collaborate.
I'm going to borrow a story
that Ian likes to tell
because I think it's particularly
salient to the conversation
that we're starting to have here
today, which is that Ian comes
from the world of history,
I come from the world
of communication research and
we often in those disciplines,
look at data, look at the data
that we're given, as a black box.
Look at the way that that data
is collected is a black box.
It sits in this box,
and we go to it,
and we say look, here's what I need.
I need some data on newspapers
in the United States,
give me what you've got.
And that data's spat out to me
and I use it and I create research
and I never really ask
how that data came to be.
And what we've started to realize is
that we need to open that black box.
And why it's so important
to have these different
disciplines represented and engaging
with one another is that by
opening up that black box,
we can start to ask some important
questions about what the data are,
how the data came to be, what some
of the underlying assumptions are,
and then how that data can better
be utilized in research to,
I was actually very excited to see
JR's slide on hotels and the map
of hotels in the United
Stated, in the world,
because I think it underscores
that problem of needing
to better understand exactly what
the data are and how they came
to be, what they mean, so that we
can better utilize them in research.
Okay. So let's put this into action.
We came up with this idea that in
order to better educate researchers,
better educate scholars
about the ways
that web archives can
be utilized in research,
we needed to create a venue for
scholars to come together to be,
to learn, to exchange ideas,
to educate one another
about the tools that are available.
And we quickly realized
it takes an army.
We've been very fortunate
to have a lot
of collaborators in this initiative.
We've had support from
our universities,
from Rutger's University, from
the University of Waterloo.
We've had support from
the Library of Congress,
from the National Science
Foundation, from the Institute
for Museum and Library
Services, the Internet Archive,
University of Toronto, and
I could go on with this,
but our list of collaborators
has really been never ending
and we're always amazed at
the people who are willing
to support us in this endeavor.
The format that we came up with was
to host a two to three day event
where we brought together an
invited group of academics,
largely graduate students,
faculty, librarians,
we start with introductions, we
start by getting people networked,
engaged with one another, we
break everyone out into teams,
into work sessions and
then we have people come
up with these presentations
based on what they did.
So let me show you a little bit
more about what that is and what
that looks like, and I'm going
to highlight the last two events
that we've hosted, the first
two events that we've hosted.
The first was Archives Unleashed
one, which we hosted in Toronto
in March, and the second
was Archives Unleashed 2.0
which we hosted in June here
at the Library of Congress.
And so what this plan
looks like in action,
is academics in the room
together are starting to engage
with one another, starting
to mingle.
And what we do is we bring these
people together, we bring our 40
to 50 scholars together into a
room, we've assembled for each
of these Archives Unleashed events,
a set of donated curated data sets.
In the case of the event that we
hosted at the Library of Congress,
we had a data set of supreme
court hearings, web archived pages
around supreme court hearings.
We had archived web pages
around the US elections.
We had archived web
pages and Twitter data
around terrorist activity, archived
known terrorist's Twitter accounts.
We had donated collections
from the Canadian government.
We put these collections
out there, we put the team,
the individuals together in a room,
and we start to ask people
what they're interested in.
And as moderators, Jimmy, Ian
and I take on this role of trying
to assemble groups into teams,
assemble individuals into teams
that are focused on
particular questions,
whether that be sentiment analysis,
event detection, and we were able,
at both of these events, to
formulate these groups of four
to five individuals that would then
spend the next two days working
together on an emergent
research questions.
In order to help to
lubricate this process,
we believe in the importance
of socialization,
and it really is critical
for these events
that it's not just everyone together
in a room, that we're getting people
out and engaged with one
another, socializing,
so absolutely the first day,
we get everyone out to a bar
in the evening, we get people
engaged with one another,
we do our fun getting to know you
games, and really break down some
of the barriers that might exist
between these individuals otherwise.
And then we come back day two, day
three, and we put everyone to work.
We spin up virtual machines using
donated competing resources,
we allow the teams to have access
to high performance computing needs,
that they would need in order to
quickly analyze and crunch the data.
But we also bring social
scientists in the fold.
We bring communication scholars,
we bring historians to the table,
so that we can also be
asking critical questions
about what the data mean.
We have a lot of applicants who will
come to us when we put the calls
out for these events, who say look,
I don't have any technical skills
but I have a lot of interesting
questions I want to ask
about web archives, these are
exactly the people we want
in the room, because we want to
be asking those critical questions
of the data that are being
extracted from web archives.
We have lightning talks where
we offer scholars an opportunity
to share the work that they're
doing, again, to build the community
and to help each other to
engage with one another.
And then ultimately, at the end,
we share the work that
we've been doing.
We come back together at the
end and present on the research
that we were able to generate and
spin up over two to three days.
This is a photo of the group
that came together for Library
of Congress, in just a couple
months since we hosted this event,
we have been following up with
everyone who participated,
and it's been amazing to
see how these teams coalesce
and how they've continued to
stay in touch with each other,
and carry on the event, the
research agendas that they started
at this two to three day workshop.
So we share, we engage, and we
ask questions of each other based
on the research that we generated.
We also form connections.
I'm an academic, I'm a researcher,
so I can't help but study the people
that we bring together, and I
have a graduate student who's very
interested in the way that
people form collaborations,
and he mapped out socio-grams,
a socio-matrix,
of the way that people connected
at the Archives Unleashed event.
This is actually based
on the Toronto event,
think back out to JR's image
of the seventh grade classroom,
this is our scholars
engaging with each other
and forming connections
just over two to three days,
and this was asking people who you
would talk to and exchanged ideas
with before the event versus
who you had exchanged ideas
with after the event, and we saw
that we formed some very
close knit groups out of this,
and close knit clusters
of researchers,
over the duration of this event.
We also of course polled individuals
to see if they were satisfied
with their experience, if they
were satisfied with the engagement,
and not that we're patting
ourselves on the back here,
but people walked away
generally happy and feeling
that they had engaged
across barriers.
We also some really cool
research coming out of this.
And it's only two to
three days, but we're able
to generate some pretty
interesting insights into the data
that we granted teams access to.
So Kate mentioned the
supreme court data,
this is a word cloud
visualization of the URLs that were
in the supreme court data,
and you start to have some
interesting head scratching moments,
for instance here seeing
doubleclick.net popping up is one
of the most prominent websites
in the supreme court data.
This is where you have
that head scratch moment,
you're like well I'm looking
at supreme court data,
why am I seeing double
click in here?
And this is where it's so helpful
to have not only the computer
scientists but humanitarians
and the people who created the
collections because we start
to realize there's some quirks
in the data, clean this out,
pull out double click,
which is an advertising hub,
an advertising website,
and we're able
to extract some more valuable
meaning around the way
that these websites are connected.
We're able to generate word clouds
around the confirmation votes
to see, to see a little bit
as to how people were voting,
whether the confirmation candidates
were being supported, not supported,
but also to see some of the
key words that were emerging
and the themes that were
emerging in the discussion
around these candidates
based on the text that was
in the archived web pages.
And again, only two to three days.
So this is an initial
snap shot here.
We're also able to move a little bit
further, I mentioned team looking
at terror risk networks
and ISIS Twitter data,
and they were actually able to take
this a little bit further and find
that there were particular types
of Twitter accounts that served
as amplifiers in, on Twitter,
to amplify certain messages
and certain themes in the
conversation, and they were able
to identify the characteristics
of those Twitter accounts based
on the data they had available.
We're moving this forward now
and we have a third event that's
tentatively planned for February
of 2017 at the Internet
Archive in San Francisco,
and we have a fourth event planned
at the British Library
in June of 2017.
And after that, we're focused now
on building a sustainable
model for this.
The work to date on Archives
Unleashed has been driven by myself,
Ian and Jimmy, and our collaborators
and that network that I mentioned
at the beginning, but we recognize
that going forward we need
to create a broader
educational model for working
with web archive data and for
educating researchers and librarians
about ways to open up
access to these data sets.
And so Kate referenced
Archives Unleashed, LLC,
we're looking to build
and we've applied
to create a nonprofit
organization around this idea
of Archives Unleashed, to built a
more sustainable educational model
for bringing together
interdisciplinary teams to engage
with web archives and to
learn the skills necessary
to create research out
of these data sets.
And so we have this long term vision
of creating a sustainable model
that will move us beyond these
Archives Unleashed events,
and build on the momentum
that we've created thus far.
If you have questions
about any of these events,
if you'd like to learn more,
I'm happy to serve as a point
of contact, so please
shoot me an e-mail.
The ArchivesUnleashed.com
website has all of the information
about the event that we
hosted at Library of Congress.
If you replace the .com with
.ca, you will find a variation
about the first event
that we hosted.
You can also access the
Archives Unleashed 1.0
and I believe the 2.0
projects are now
up as well, via that bitley link.
It's also linked via
ArchivesUnleashed.com.
And thank you again for
having me here today,
thank you again for listening.
We really appreciate your time.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> Hi, can you hear me?
Great.
[ Background Noise ]
>> Do you have slides for us?
Oh.
>> Leah Weinryb Grohsgal: Cool.
Thank you.
Thank you partner.
Good morning, yes,
a round of applause.
Good morning, I'm Leah
Weinryb Grohsgal,
I'm a senior program officer in the
division of preservation and access
at the National Endowment
for the Humanities,
and I'm also the program
coordinator for NEH
for the National Digital
Newspaper program.
This is Deb Thomas, Deborah
Thomas, she is the program manager
for the National Digital Newspaper
program at the Library of Congress.
So the NDNP is a partnership between
NEH and the Library of Congress,
that represents a long term
effort between these two agencies
to develop Chronicling America,
an open access searchable database
of historic US newspapers.
And Kate talked about
sustained efforts,
this is really the culmination
sort of, of a sustained effort.
This program's been going on for
10 plus years, and it also builds
on the US newspaper
program, which was the effort
to microfilm all those historic
newspapers before they fell away
to dust.
At this point, we have millions
of pages of digitized newspapers
and descriptive information
contributed by states
and territories across the country.
One of the best things
about NDNP is that Library
of Congress has made
all of the data open.
And they've developed a well
documented API to explore it
in a number of different ways.
It's an incredible collection of
data, that's just waiting to be used
for scholarship, research,
education and public programming.
I'm here to tell you about a
successful contest I ran at NEH
to encourage creative
and substantial use of
Chronicling America.
First, Deb is going to
go over the goals of NDNP
and explain the data she and her
colleagues have made available,
and after that, I'll
describe the data challenge
and the excellent results.
Deb.
>> Deborah Thomas: Thank you Leah.
So I made the magic happen, but
now I don't know what I'm doing.
[ Background Noise ]
Ah ha. Alright, well, so this is
newspapers, historic newspapers
in particular, and I'm just going
to show you a few,
oops, that was accident.
I'm going to show you a few
of examples of newspapers.
That may or may not
show up on the screen.
Anyway, newspapers have something
in them for any kind of discipline
or humanities studies
or social sciences.
As you can see from the images
in the background there
are advertisements,
there are news articles
on scientific events,
there's economic articles, there's
genealogy, there's literature,
any kind of thing you want to study
can be found in historic newspapers.
The goals of the National
Digital Newspaper Program
in particular were primarily
to enhance access to
American newspapers.
We are, our whole goal
with the program was
to create a national
level collection
of what is currently
today, a distributed level,
a distributed collection
across the United States.
The Library of Congress
has a very large collection
of American historic
newspapers, but is not,
is has a particular collection
focus, it is not the collection
of American history newspapers.
The collection of American historic
newspapers is actually stored
in state libraries and
archives around the country.
And so using digital technologies,
we're able to bring this
material back together again
through the partnerships
with the National Endowment
for the Humanities and
individual state institutions,
representing their
state in the program.
We have developed a permanent
digital resource including selected
historical content from
each, from the states
that are currently participating.
Eventually we hope to cover all 50
states, as well as many territories
as are able to participate.
The structure of the program is
focused around shared resources.
We share the cost of the program
with the National Endowment
for thr Humanities,
the National Endowment
for the Humanities provides
funding to each state to select
and digitize materials from
their state collections,
their newspaper collections,
based on some basic criteria
that we provide, and they
digitize their collections
to specifications established
by the Library of Congress,
the Library of Congress receives the
data, aggregates it, and sustains it
for the long term and makes
it available to the public.
One of the key elements of the
program over the past 10 years
and into the future is
focusing on paste scalability,
so that the Library of Congress
and the National Endowment
for the Humanities can make this
program last into the long term,
essentially so and to ensure that
the data that we get at the end
of the program is similar to the
data, is usable with the data
that we get in the
beginning of the program.
So we have gradually increased
the size of the program.
We started in 2005
with six awardees,
which seemed like a moderate amount
of people to start working with,
and now we're up to working with
more than 40 states and territories
and we have many, many,
many millions of newspapers.
In addition to all those aspects
of actually creating the content
and bringing the content
together, we focus the structure
of the program and the resources on
planning ahead for technical change
and sustainability in the
fact that we have ensured,
and through various mechanisms,
that the data that we receive
is all fairly consistent.
We have a very detailed
technical specification,
which while has been described
as richly detailed, we're,
we have a fair level of confidence
that this material is in fact going
to last into the future,
and whatever the next form
that this digital data needs to
take, to be usable in the systems
of the future, we can move it in
that direction as a whole data set
and we won't be dealing
with individual pieces
from 50 different producers.
So this is a screen shot of the
Chronicling America website,
it's LOC.gov/chroniclingamerica,
it's chroniclingamerica.loc.gov
or the historic newspapers'
badge from the Library
of Congress home page, it provides
access to searching the newspapers
and browsing them as well.
And this is the user
interface available.
This is a map of the states
participating in the program so far.
As you can see, it's
happily very green.
We're still working on filling
in all those other little spots,
but this year we just, NEH just
announced grants to Alaska,
Colorado, Maine and New Jersey.
We're very happy to have
them join the program
and join the other
40 states including
and territories including Puerto
Rico and the District of Columbia
which the Library of Congress
represents, which is all available
in the Chronicling America website.
So currently the status
of the website,
is today we have 11.3
million pages online, we have,
that's approximately 75
terabytes of live storage,
and we also have 750
terabytes of archival storage,
the master archival files are
kept offline for safe keeping.
We have 44 states and
territories participating
in the program actively, we
have representation content
from 40 states and territories.
We also have, in addition to the
actual digitized newspaper pages,
one of the tasks of the awardees,
when they select the digitized,
the newspapers they
want to digitize,
is to create a 500 word essay
about the significant historical
context of that newspaper.
Why was this one particularly
important enough to make available?
To digitize and make available?
And so we have 1,100 of these essays
that have been written by scholars
and knowledgeable researchers
around, and librarians
from the country, that really
put the newspapers in those,
in their place in time, and
explain why these were significantly
important content.
In addition, just the 11
million pages represent 2,100
different titles.
But that, I talked a little
bit about, we, one of the goals
of the program is to create a
selected amount of content available
through this program and through
the Library of Congress website.
That's a selected amount of
content because at 11 million pages,
we're only working with
2,100 titles so far?
Out of the 153,000 titles that have
been published in the United States.
That gives you a little bit of a
sense of the scale of newspapers
that have been published
in the United States.
This is always ever going
to be a slice off the top,
and hopefully it's a very rich
and valuable slice to
researching scholars.
And in addition, for reasons
of sustainability in archiving,
we have 10,000 reels of microfilm
that were created during
the digitization process.
So just a glimpse into what
the site allows you to do.
The search has, the site
has two main features.
One is the digitized newspapers,
which are full text
search-able at the page level.
You can search by place,
time and key word,
which are the really
the important things
when you're looking at newspapers.
You have a certain a mount of
information about every issue
and page, you can navigate
within them,
you have visual search
highlights that are in red.
I don't know if you can see
it on this screen or not,
that indicate where your
key words occur in the page,
and that gives you the chance
to zero in visually on articles
of interest and where your
results may be, you may be willing
to spend the time zooming and
panning into the materials.
In addition, there's the ability to
manipulate the image on the screen
and to make it full screen.
The other kind of data,
which is also part
of the Chronicling America website,
is the US newspaper directory.
This sort of forms the backbone
of all of the newspapers
that we might want to digitize,
and actually represents the program
that Leah mentioned,
the USNP program,
the United States Newspaper Program,
which was structured to identify,
catalog and selectively
microfilm the nation's newspapers.
All the records that were
cataloged under that program,
the 150,000 titles that we
know that have been published
in the United States, if they
have digitized content elsewhere,
it's the records and they provide
more information for resources
that enhances access to the
newspaper, more information
for researchers and enhances access
to newspapers across the country.
So the US newspaper directory
is also search-able by place,
time and key word, and
it includes website links
to individual locations where
these materials may be found,
as well as holdings records.
And finally, well not
quite finally, but close,
what's available and
how is it available?
Leah mentioned open access to
this data, well what that means is
that the data is available for
harvesting for reuse outside
of the individual interfaces that
we provide through the website.
So we have digitized page images,
we have objectable
character recognition
which is machine readable text for
all the pages, we have meta-data
that surrounds every page and issue,
which is in a standardized
METS format
in MODS descriptive characters,
descriptive characteristics,
which describes the place and time
of that particular issue as well
as the newspaper directory records.
All of these pieces can be taken
out of the site and analyzed
in different ways by
researchers or individuals,
that don't involve the
actual web, website.
So the way that we make the data
available is through the open API
as well through the public website.
We provide stable URLs that
are helpful for many reasons,
in particular, they are
machine, human readable,
so that you can project and predict
what the next URL you might be
accessing could be.
There are machine readable
views like JASON [assumed],
which makes it a bit easier
to play with the stuff.
And there are prefab data sets
that we have created specifically
for the, on the request of
researchers who really just wanted
to access the OCR for example, so
we have created batched downloads
that people can access and take
away for use and manipulation later.
And now I will turn it
over to Leah to to tell you
about the specific uses
that have been made of late.
>> Leah Weinryb Grohsgal: Alright.
Cool. Thanks Deb.
So you just heard about the
incredible amount of data
that we have available
and the number of ways
that researchers can access it.
Chronicling America is
an exceptionally valuable
and public spacing product.
It's one of the best known and most
used resources that's ever been
produced by both NEH and
the Library of Congress.
As a historian myself, I used
the site well before I came
to NEH for my own research.
The site's used heavily
through the user interface
and there have been a few large
scale digital humanities projects
done with the open data that
are really cool to look at.
But we at NEH wanted to see even
more people using the open data.
And NEH we decided to try hosting
a contest to get people thinking
about creating interesting projects.
So we used challenge.gov, which
is a platform for agencies
across the federal government
to host competitions.
It's been around since 2010 and it's
a response to the White House office
of science and technology policy's
call for government agencies
to promote innovation using
prizes and challenges.
Our challenge encouraged members
of the public to ask the question,
how can you use open
data to explore history?
We purposely left the
challenges parameters broad,
and we encouraged entrants
to be creative in thinking
about what humanities themes
really interested them,
and how they would get at
that through the open data.
So projects could create
maps, visualizations or tools,
and entrants also were
allowed to mash up the data
in Chronicling America
with other data sets
in order to get their results.
Because the Chronicling
America database covers so much
in these millions of pages from
north to south, east to west,
across the country,
various political, religious
and cultural standpoints, we really
think that the sky is the limit.
And we had prizes!
We got many interesting entries.
I don't have too much time to
go too deeply into any of them,
but I think a short look at each
of the six winners
will give you a taste
of the variety of projects we got.
You can find links and more
information about the winners
and their projects on the NEH
website if you're interested.
Our first prize winner
was Lincoln Mullin,
for a site entitled
America's Public Bible,
bible quotations in US Newspapers.
The site tracks biblical
quotations in American newspapers,
to see how the bible was
used for cultural, social,
religious or political purposes.
It shows how the bible was
a contested yet common text,
so you'll find quotations
in things like sermons
in Sunday School lessons, which
were reprinted in newspapers
across the country, but you can also
find the bible used in every side
of almost every issue
including slavery,
women's suffrage and capitalism.
Next we had a tie for second place.
One second prize winner is by Andrew
Bales, entitled American Lynching,
uncovering a cultural narrative.
This site explores America's long
and dark history with lynching,
in which newspapers acted as both
a catalyst for public killings
and a platform for
advocating reform.
Bales integrated the Chronicling
America data with data sets
on lynching for Tuskegee
University as well as project HAL
which is based on the bectonay
[assumed] confirmed inventory.
The site is intended to tell
the story of lynching in America
through maps and other
visualizations as we often do
with data but Bales also
wants to connect that data
with the stories of the victims.
Oops. Sorry, I didn't
advance the slide.
That's a quick look.
The other second prize went
to Amy Glroux, Marcy Galbreth
and Nathan Glroux for
Historical Agricultural news.
This is a search tool
for exploring information
on the farming organizations,
technologies
and practices of America's past.
The group sees farming as
window into all kinds of things
about American history
including social,
economic, political and cultural.
Additionally, they see their project
focusing on one subject area as sort
of a statement about big data.
So by narrowing it down
into this one subject area,
they've created a useful data
set that can be kind of extracted
from this massive data in case
people maybe don't know what to do
with it because there's
so much of it.
So the challenge's third
prize was also a tie.
One third prize went to another
team, Kristi Palmer, Kaitlin Polick
and Ted Polly, for
Chronicling Hoosier.
This site tracks the
origins of the word Hoosier,
it's geographic distribution,
and its positive
and negative connotations over time.
The project uses visualizations
that are all connected
with Chronicling America to
tell the story of the word,
which is not what you might expect.
Additionally, they have documented
and made all of their code open,
so that anyone inclined to do
so can apply it to another word
that they're interested in.
The other third prize award went
to another team, Claudio Saunt
and Trevor Goodyear
for Usnewsmap.com.
Saunt and Goodyear made a
really interesting point
when they're explaining
the origins of the project.
So many people use Google
engrams viewer in order
to track public discourse
across the United States.
But books take time to write and
publish, and many times they come
out in multiple editions,
years apart,
potentially skewing the
results if you're looking
at what people were talking
about at any given time.
Because of their quick
publication schedule,
newspapers capture the
public discourse better
than almost anything else.
So this site is built on
the Chronicling America data
and allows users to
discover patterns
and watch news go viral so to speak.
For example, you can track terms
like miscegenation and scalawag
which quickly gained currency
in the 1860s in response
to the political situation.
And finally, we awarded a K
through 12 educational prize,
which this year went to teacher Ray
Palin and the AP US History students
at Sunapee High school in Sunapee
New Hampshire, for Digital APUSH,
revealing history with
Chronicling America.
So this group of 15 students
used word frequency analysis,
which is a kind of distant
reading, according to them,
to discover patterns
in news coverage.
They broke into teams and researched
issues that caught their interest.
For example, the case Plessy
vs Ferguson, the words secede
and secession, Uncle Tom's
Cabin, the KKK, and labor unions.
According to Palin, the project
was similar to the usual assignment
of writing a paper
in that students had
to identify an important
historical question and think
about ways to research the answer.
Using data, however, allowed them
to learn a whole different set
of skills than writing
a research paper.
So I realize I didn't have
much time to go into much depth
about these projects, but
only to provide teasers,
just to indicate the vast
array of subjects represented.
I do think that this contest
holds several lessons for those
of us interested in
collections as data.
First, know your collections.
I've been interested in the
kinds of projects that could come
out of Chronicling America
since before working at NEH,
when as a historian, I used
the site for my own research
on civil liberties, religious
groups and free speech.
Additionally, as a librarian, the
site is also important to me as one
of the only freely accessible
sources for historic news.
The collection holds so many
possibilities as a data set
that it was good to see the
field respond to this challenge.
Many of the winners sheepishly
told us that they were happy
about the contest because it
gave them a deadline to a project
that they had been intending
to do for a long time.
It may not be possible always
to hold a contest like this,
but it might be something
to think about if you want
to gather a critical mass of
people working on your collection
and stir up excitement about it.
I want to call attention to how many
team projects we had here as well.
And I think that it's
important to remember that a lot
of times we have people
working together outside
of traditional academic department
and crossing departmental lines
and we should encourage
this in any way that we can.
I think that the high school
teacher Mr. Palin pointed
out that academic value of these
projects extends well beyond second,
what he pointed out extends
well beyond the lessons
in secondary school
that he is teaching.
This intellectual work really
involves, as he pointed out,
similar question identifying
to any sort of research
and should be valued in the
academic community no matter what
you're doing.
And finally, I think this
contest points to the importance
with any collection
of maintaining contact
with the communities
using the product.
Not just putting the data
out there, but really trying
to understand how people are
inclined to use the collection,
and learning from them
at the same time
that they learn from the collection.
Thank you very much, and we're happy
to answer any questions, you know,
during the course of the meeting.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.